well i had a good conversation with the
president yesterday afternoon before he
made his announcement and we've been
talking trying to work on a deal for
about the last three months and
ultimately we just couldn't come to
terms that both of us could agree to of
course he's the one who literally wrote
the book the art of the deal so he knows
a thing about uh or two about deal
making
but i think quite frankly it's it's good
to have more competition in the
environment i think this is going to
pull even more people away from facebook
and twitter which i think are largely
dying platforms and this gives us the
opportunity to shine as we start to
introduce more features
what was it that you couldn't agree with
him on
well i think uh first and foremost
probably the number of zeroes uh that
were in the the figure that we were
talking about i think we had more
zeros in there than elizabeth taylor had
husbands so it's a pretty hefty package
but it sounds like he uh thought he had
a better deal elsewhere but i ultimately
think they'd get her with our superior
technology with the fact that we're
rolling out the live streaming as we
start moving into uh some of the
financial payments uh moving into our
own version of instagram reels or even
facebook stories it really is a step
above and as i've been traveling the
world i've been to london twice just in
the past month of berlin and paris uh
brazil which got a lot of attention
everybody keeps saying the same thing
who elected these social media oligarchs
in silicon valley to dictate our free
speech rights people want to be heard
and they're tired of being censored
interesting that you said it was about
the number of zeros do you think that
this for donald trump is about getting
his voice out there because he doesn't
have any other social media platform on
which you can do that or is it about
monetizing it and making a quick buck
well i think he probably has a goal for
both and i think if you take a look at
their media plan that they put together
in addition to the social media platform
that sounds like they want to go into
some of the content production uh they
want to go into movies and television
shows and things like that whereas we
have the social media platform and as we
build this community we want to in
addition to being the global leaders for
free speech we also want to get into the
digital uh economy and make sure that
we're introducing people around the
world to
digital currency as well as uh crypto
and blockchain a number of other things
so i think ultimately our paths will
diverge a little bit but it all starts
with having that community for free
speech and the president if he's gonna
run again 2024 needs a platform
um
they've been called dying platforms
what what evidence is there that they
are dying platforms they seem you know
well
subscribed to well we know that twitter
yeah we know that twitter lost a lot of
followers after they kicked president
trump off i can tell you from our own
market research uh that both facebook
and twitter have lost significant
numbers after president trump what a
significant number sorry sorry to jump
in there how many significant numbers
what is that no i i can tell you that
upwards yeah no upwards of 25 to 30
percent of all trump voters left social
media after he was de-platformed earlier
this year and that's something that
you're quite frankly not hearing enough
about in the news a lot of people have
just said we're not going to be on there
with these big tech oligarchs from
silicon valley playing judge during
executioner with our free speech rights
now that we have getter for example
we've we're almost at 3 million users
just since we launched in july fastest
ever platform to 1 million fastest ever
to 2 million and again this is something
we've seen global in fact the u.s
is less than half of our user base it's
only about 47 japan and brazil are both
right around 14
uh uk is about three and a half percent
but hopefully after a big event coming
up on december 8th the counter
conference that we just announced and
we're bringing people together talk
about saving western civilization our
numbers will go up even higher
the left or the right neither of them
like the big tech
do they
so it's interesting that you say that i
think that's a pretty smart observation
because that was really the i think the
buried lead in the facebook
whistleblower um drama from a week or
two back so much of the attention was
around
the fact that this whistleblower had
more left to center political leanings
but the fact that you now have the left
and the right who are both attacking big
tech shows that people are frustrated
keep in mind in 2016 president trump
actually got i believe it was eight or
nine percent of the bernie sanders
voters in the general election the
ideological spectrum isn't so much of a
flat line it's really a circle and a lot
of people just really resist having big
government or
big tech controlling so many aspects of
their lives and i think that's why we're
seeing such growth with getter and other
free speech outlets
um you spoke to donald trump yesterday
did you say it was
i spoke with him yesterday and then i
last saw him in person about 10 days or
so ago but we had a good conversation
and uh lively banter as there always is
with both the president and myself and
uh both of us kind of reminded the other
person that how strong allies we've been
through two presidential campaigns and
how we want to continue working together
on number of things on this one
particular instance we're going to be
competitors but i think it'll be it'll
be fun and like i said if he's pulling
more of his people who have left social
media that 25 30 percent of his base who
have quit social media since he got
kicked off if he's bringing them back
into the digital realm then i think once
they see getter we'll have a chance to
go and bring him on and so i think this
ultimately for the long term will be a
good thing if having people re-energized
uh and reorganized i think this will be
a good thing for getter also in in that
conversation was there any any at any
point did you discuss working on a third
presidential campaign with him
uh no comment no i'll i'll say that
as i told the president i've told him
numerous times because he has not yet
made a uh has not yet made a formal uh
announcement even behind the scenes he
doesn't say uh you know he's made it
clear he's not made a decision uh but
also made it clear to the president that
if he runs again i'll be there to help
him maybe in a slightly smaller time
capacity than my normal 18 or 19 hour
days when i've worked for him in the
past since i'm busy running a global
company myself but of course i'll be
there to help him for anything that he
does